DOWN.
GOBBLE UP FOR ANOTHER RIDE ON
THE WALL STREET ROLLER COASTER.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I’M CHRIS WALLACE IN FOR A
BRET BAIER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE WAS
SURPRISED ABOUT DOMESTIC ABUSE
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST ONE OF HIS
TOP AIDES AND WISHES HIM WELL IN
THE FUTURE PRINCE -- SECRETARY
ROB PORTER HAS CLEANED OUT HIS
DESK, BUT THERE APPEARS TO BE
INCREASING PRESSURE ON OTHER
TRUMP AIDS ABOUT WHEN THEY KNEW
THE ACCUSATION.
KEVIN CORKE TELLS US JUST
BECAUSE PORTER IS DONE DOES NOT
MEAN THE CONTROVERSY IS GOING
AWAY.
GOOD EVENING, KEVIN.
>> YOU ARE RIGHT ON THE MONEY,
CHRIS.
ROB PORTER’S CAREER AT THE
WHITE HOUSE MAY BE OVER, BUT
THERE ARE INCREASING NEW
QUESTIONS TONIGHT WHEN
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS FIRST
BECAME AWARE OF THE ALLEGATIONS
SURROUNDING THEIR FORMER STAFF
SECRETARY.
>> WE DID A VERY GOOD JOB WHEN
HE WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE AND WE
HOPE HE HAS A WONDERFUL CAREER.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL HAVE A GREAT
CAREER AHEAD OF HIM.
>> THE PRESIDENT’S COMMENTS
ABOUT ROB PORTER DID NOT QUELL
THE CONTROVERSY SURROUNDING THE
WHITE HOUSE’S HANDLING OF THE
FORMER STAFF SECRETARY’S
DEPARTURE.
IF ANYTHING, HE MAY HAVE IGNITED
ANYONE.
>> AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW, HE SAYS
HE’S INNOCENT.
BUT I THINK YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT.
FIRST HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT
HE’S INNOCENT.
YOU HAVE TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT
THAT.
>> DESPITE PORTER’S REVIEW THE
DENIAL AND WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE
LEARNED ABOUT THE FIRST
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM, THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR WOMEN
CALLED ON WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF JOHN TILLICH TO RESIGN,
SAYING THE RETIRED MARINE
GENERAL WAS "AN ENABLER OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE."
THAT FOLLOWED REPORTS OF KELLY
"THE WASHINGTON POST" SAID
MCGHAN FIRST LEARNED ABOUT THE
REPORTS IN JANUARY.
IN SEPTEMBER, THE NEWS FINALLY
REACHED KELLY, BUT PORTER STAYED
ON THE JOB UNTIL PHOTOS OF THE
ALLEGED ABUSE SURFACED THIS
WEEK.
>> NO QUESTION THEY COULD’VE
HANDLED IT BETTER.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE PROCESS THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE IN PLACE
FAILED.
THE CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT
SHOULD’VE BEEN IN PLACE FAILED.
THE PUBLIC REPORTS NOW SAY
MULTIPLE PEOPLE WERE MADE AWARE
OF THIS OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST FEW MONTHS.
>> KELLY WROTE TO STAFF
YESTERDAY IN PART, "I WANT YOU
TO KNOW THAT WE TAKE MATTERS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SERIOUSLY.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IS IMPORTANT
AND ONE HAS NO PLACE IN OUR
SOCIETY."
IT’S NOT THE FIRST TIME KELLY
HAS FOUND HIMSELF IN THE CENTER
OF THE WHITE HOUSE CONTROVERSY.
IN AN INTERVIEW WITH FOX NEWS’
P26, HE SUGGESTED THE PRESIDENT
WAS EVOLVING ON OR BEFORE THE
BORDER WALL," SOMETHING THE
PRESIDENT TONIGHT ON TWITTER.
HE SAID SOME UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS WERE TOO LAZY TO SIGN
THREE DACA, AND ACCUSED A
FLORIDA CONGRESSWOMAN OF
GRANDSTANDING A BUILDING